it looks like apple has finally lost the
battle and they are admitting that they
were wrong but don't worry that is good
news for you and for me because the
iPhone and iPad are about to change
forever in some pretty good ways check
out this report from Mark German the
most prominent Apple leaker out there
new story apple is preparing to allow
alternative app stores Yes you heard
that correctly third party app stores on
your iPhone and iPad and side loading on
iOS yes remember what Apple band they
are bringing it back along with a slew
of other changes to make the iPhone more
open finally in response to new European
Union requirements arriving in
2024. man Apple must really hate those
Regulators over in the EU but on the
positive side digging into this article
it looks like the news of Apple allowing
outside app stores has triggered stock
surges for dating services and other
apps of course because they're going to
be able to charge more because of those
third-party app stores on the iPhone now
as soon as this news broke for Mark
German the first thing that came to my
mind was Tim Sweeney over at epic games
with that whole fortnite debacle look at
this tweet right here looks like epic is
bringing back fortnite to iOS devices
with their own app store yes it looks
like they have finally won the battle
because if you didn't already know apple
and epic games have been in court over
lawsuits over the past couple of years
since way back in
2020. now if you don't remember what
happened Apple kicked fortnite off of
the App Store completely that was a
whole ton of drama and of course it made
sense because they violated their terms
of service because epic came out with
this crazy video how they showed them
fighting back against the big guy the
Big Apple and epic basically came out
with a new software update in fortnite
allowing new direct payment on IOS and
Android to get around the App Store fees
and you can see a screenshot right here
where they literally showed that you can
get a better discounted price if you use
epic direct payment which of course
Apple did not like and of course more
recently we started seeing that in other
areas where Twitter with their new
Twitter Blue from Elon Musk is charging
11 per month for Twitter blue if you're
on your iPhone or you can just go to the
website and pay only seven dollars of
course the people actually spending the
money are going to be going to the
website so it caused a bunch of drama
with apple but Elon Musk went and he met
with Tim Cook so they I guess solved all
the issues that they had but
nevertheless it looks like apple is
finally crumbling over all of that
pressure from The Regulators but the
interesting thing that I noticed with
the replies to this tweet from Mark
German is check this out if this is true
then I think I'll finally shift to
iPhone side loading is a big deal for me
I may finally shift to iPhone dang I
might actually get an iPhone and this
guy once again looks like a lot of
people might actually start buying
iPhones because of these changes so
maybe just maybe it might be worth it
for Apple to do this of course they're
being forced to do it but it might lead
to more people switching from Android
over to iPhone which is of course what
Apple wants now getting into some of the
replies and quote tweets from The Tech
Community Jeff Benjamin who used to run
YouTube for nine to five Max said that
as a former Jailbreaker this is surreal
talking about how he used to use
jailbreak breaking to get special
features on his iPhone so this is some
pretty interesting stuff at least in his
perspective and somebody else replied
that's crazy it's going to open up so
many opportunities now Dylan mcd8 he
said wow I hate it side loading is great
but an alternative app store horrible
and I'll explain why he says this in
just a minute and of course Joe from Mac
Rumors saying not sure that Apple has
much of a choice in the EU but whoa yes
I was shocked as well and then Max
Weinbach saying who's ready to import
iPhones from Europe now I'm not sure if
this is how it works with it being
hard-coded into the hardware like some
people are believing because it might be
location based that'd be crazy if you
could actually buy a European iPhone and
get this stuff to work now of course
that's because if you read more deeply
into what Mark German said it's not
going to be rolling out worldwide at
least right away basically only where
where they are required to by law and
sarenbeit says that there's no way
they're going to be rolling out access
to third-party app stores worldwide
however you really have to think about
this because if Apple goes this step to
allowing third-party app stores in the
EU basically the rest of the world is
gonna be like hey I want this I want
this in my country all the consumers are
going to demand it they're going to want
it because of all the EU people talking
about it and saying how awesome it's
going to be maybe that might actually
put a lot of pressure on Apple to bring
it worldwide and if you think about it
it's just like the whole USBC situation
where EU passed laws to make the iPhone
the forced to switch to USBC by the end
of
2024 but the crazy thing is that Ming
shiko said that we might actually get
the iPhone 15 next year switching over
to USBC and that is probably going to be
world worldwide all iPhones even in the
US might switch the USBC because of
what's going on over in the EU so we
might see the same thing happening with
this whole third-party App Store thing
now Sammy from Mac rumor said that this
is obviously big news but the real
juices and the details who decides what
type of alternative app distribution
platforms are available do side loaded
apps have the same privileges as app
store apps what security and privacy
precautions are in place now if you
don't remember Tim Cook actually talked
about side loading back in April and why
it's bad for digital privacy and that's
because you're opening up your device to
Alternative threats or third-party
threats when you're going over to
different apps that are not fully
licensed and certified for the iPhone
but surprisingly according to mark
gurtman it looks like they are folding
and they're gonna have to do it based on
the EU law now in my opinion I think
apple is going to you wait in some sort
of way where they can comply with the
laws but do kind of like the minimal
effort or at least make it very
complicated or confusing or difficult to
make it happen so that people will still
prefer to buy directly from the IOS app
store because that's going to be the
most convenient way but the real techies
that really want to side load apps or
download from third-party app stores
they're going to be able to do so but
now digging into Mark German's tweet
thread it could get even better because
these changes could also be coming to
the NFC chip and camera access basically
not having it as locked down and
allowing you to connect to different
devices the find my network for Rivals
to the air tag so that's going to really
help those other businesses that used to
thrive but now got killed by the ear tag
web browsing engines so not only just
Safari and other areas of Apple software
that is huge for other people trying to
compete with Apple's locked down
ecosystem and of course this might be
why some people might switch over to the
iPhone finally but with that said it
seems like apple is finally losing out
on this battle especially since Elon
Musk has joined the battle in terms of
Twitter and all the IOS app store fees
so there's pressure from the Twitter
side and then if you look at Epic Games
check this out only recently the CEO Tim
Sweeney said that he's willing to go to
the Supreme Court to battle Apple's
control of the App Store and of course
that's something that apple does not
want they don't want extra attention so
maybe to avoid all of this they might be
finally folding under the pressure and
changing their ways which is of course
good for everybody especially the tech
enthusiasts out there and with that said
we might finally see The Return of
fortnight on iOS not just through
GeForce now cloud gaming services but it
looks like epic might finally bring
their own app store over to the iPhone
however it's not all good news because
there could be some issues with this
according to Maxim Samuel lenko on
Twitter saying that multiple times
members of my family would either be
unable to download an app or it would
download a bunch of malware and viruses
because they'd have to go outside of an
app store on certain platforms so
basically there's a chance that people
could be running into some issues with
malware or whatever else because they're
not staying on the secure IOS app store
if apple is forced to open up their
iPhones and iPads to third-party app
stores so I'm not sure about all this
let me know what you think if this is
going to be a good idea or a bad one
down in the comment section below low
but if you might finally be switching to
an iPhone because of news like this
definitely check out the latest iPhone
14 pro using the product tagging YouTube
feature if you enjoyed this video click
the circle button to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]